Cameron is in Arizona hi Cameron welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hey thanks so
much for taking my car I feel honored
and kind of blessed to be talking with
you today you too sir how can I help ya
so just a little bit of a backstory I'm
24 years old I'm married my wife and I
have one child about a year and a half
but we are currently in a pretty
financial situation we do have about
$4,000 in my wife student loans and
we've got about 7200 in some hospital
bills so right around 11,000 is where we
sit with that so my wife and I you know
I love her more than anything on this
planet where we're super partners and we
compromise on a lot of things but I'm
sure you know in marriage you you pick
your battles you win some and you lose
some and I feel like I'm kind of losing
the bottle on showing her the value and
what Financial Peace University could
bring to our marriage and how it could
help us pass them in this debt and I'm
just looking for some advice maybe some
words that you might be able to provide
me that I have not already how old is
she I at least 22 right now I'm 24 and
how long have y'all been married we've
been married for about three years now
how often how many times a month do you
eat pizza
do you eat pizza well she doesn't like
cheese you know so we go he keeps it all
that often but we go out to eat so what
do you support you how many time what do
you spend on restaurants a month I'd say
we're about 200 so you go out twice um
we we go out once a week but we're
pretty frugal with what we spend around
25 bucks a week yeah okay so for half of
what you're spending on restaurants a
month you can learn how to handle money
right and so and I see the value in that
she seems to think I wasn't trying to
talk to you I'm giving you as an answer
your question it said the arm you know
it's
kind of crazy that you guys are willing
to spend that kind of money on
entertainment and not spend any on
improving yourselves right and that's
what I would bring up you know oh you
know people spend more on cable in a lot
of cases than they do and they haven't
read a nonfiction book or done anything
to get better at their life in in a
decade you know and so because they
don't have the money to go to that class
and one of the money to take that to
take that course none of the money to
attend that seminar you know and they do
have the monies my opponent you're just
spending it on entertainment and on
other stuff what's your household income
were commission-based
we're making anywhere between 45 and 55
a year right now good for you
well done well done well I think it's
this the number one cause of divorce you
know it could sound like this honey the
number one cause of divorce in North
America today and the number one cause
of marital discord a family of marriage
people fighting is money if we could
learn how to handle that number one
problem in marriage better I think
there's no question it's gonna make our
marriage better and I think it's no
question about your money better and so
just trust me on this and go with me and
this is something I want to do and trust
me and go with me and you know if that's
not losing a battle I mean it's just
it's like saying I don't want to eat
that kind of food well I want to go
there one time and try this restaurant
okay well let's go it's about the same
kind of money I mean it really is and so
that's what the decision you guys have
got to make hey thanks for joining us